hi everyone I'm here with International
Master gunai Mama Zada who just won her
game hi good night
thank you for joining me for a short
interview congratulations first of all
um I know you got a little bit lucky
today with the win how do you feel it's
the first round is always nice to win
um I mean there's not much thing to say
because she just pondered in the opening
I don't know why I suppose she doesn't
play Maroon so we transposed it from the
Knight of three Knight F6 to that
position
so I suppose just she wasn't really
aware of the opening and there she had
to play Bishop D7 and the queen D2 and
that G4 so it would be her accurate idea
but yeah where you should play it is
just wonder yeah she probably missed 96
1966 or Bishop takes eight one of those
uh probably still jet like how do you
feel yourself I know you you came
the day before so you had maybe a day to
come back how do you feel with the time
different time zone and everything it's
just a bit hard because I was expecting
that I would be accommodating earlier so
I was kind of sleeping today
but it's nice that I finished with with
the weaning and so I can have a rest
more okay I won't keep you much thanks
so much for stopping by good luck in the
future rounds and uh hopefully you get
some rest and ready for a future video
games thank you